it was Donald Trump he made everybody
even if you weren't politically inclined
you suddenly had an opinion yeah you
know what I mean for sure couldn't look
away yeah so I didn't have there was no
political inclinations in my house my
parents were not politically engaged my
grandparents I who I grew up for a good
portion of my childhood in their home
weren't politically engaged so I would
say I came from a very apolitical family
but of course left leaning because
you're black and you're supposed to be a
Democrat so that's just kind of the
cultural poisoning that goes on in 2015
Trump came on the escalator I remember
thinking like I don't want this guy to
win because not because of any reason
other than he's an Entertainer you know
exactly so to me it was it was like if
someone like Hulk Hogan was running I
would just be like oh no he's an
Entertainer you know it didn't it didn't
feel appropriate after Obama was in
office and then I watched a speech that
he gave in Dimond Del Michigan and he
made this very interesting elevator
pitch to Black America and he was kind
of just listing through all of the
actual factual statistics in Black
America of like this is the poverty rate
this is whatever it is and at the end
he's just like I mean did you try
something different what do you have to
lose and I was like that's a pretty good
business pitch